Lenard leo is the executive vice
president of the Federalist Society
that's a group of conservative lawyers
who want judges to interpret the law as
it was written he advises President
Trump on judicial nominations and spoke
to the president yesterday following the
announcement of Justice Kennedy's
retirement hello Leonard Leo good
morning to you good morning do you want
to share what you spoke with the
president about yesterday what you
talked about well the president mainly
talked about the great meeting he had
with Justice Kennedy and how gracious
the Justice was and how how much the
president respects the many years of
service that Justice Kennedy had can you
share with us how this list came about
and how you decide who should make the
list well the list was the president's
idea he actually called and asked to
meet and suggested the idea of doing a
list it was a novel idea I told him that
no one had ever done it before but it
was an interesting idea because it would
tell people where the president stood on
the issue of judicial Selection and so
he went ahead and decided to do the list
what do you say was looking for well he
was looking for three things one
extraordinarily well-qualified two
people who were in his words not weak
and thirdly people who were going to
interpret the Constitution the way the
framers meant it to be which is the way
he put it which I thought was an
interesting way to do it you're being
humble Leonard but you have really been
credited along with the Federal Society
of being involved in really the the
picks for the last three Supreme Court
justices Roberts the chief Alito and
Gorsuch would you say that that's true
well presidents always make these
choices but there's no question that
there's been a long-standing movement in
the United States to appoint judges to
the court or gonna interpret the law as
it's written and I'm a part of that
certainly three concerns on the court
let me read this has been said about you
quote no one has been more dedicated to
the enterprise of building a Supreme
Court that will overturn Roe vs. Wade
than the federal societies Leonard leo
do you believe with this pick replacing
Kennedy could finally be the nail in the
coffin of abortion rights roe v wade has
been a scare tactic that's gone back 36
years go all the way back to Justice
Sandra O'Connor's nomination to the
court and you know nothing has happened
to Roe in that period of time and for me
it's not about roe v wade for
constitutional conservatives that's not
what it's about it's about interpreting
the cost
as it's written and basically
interpreting the limits on government
power because that's really the way to
preserve human dignity in our country I
hear you but should we be worried about
roe v wade going away I don't think
people should be worried about roe v
wade or any other particular case I
think that should be worried about
having judges we're really going to
interpret the laws it's written and I'm
going to understand that the culture and
the political process need to make big
decisions in our in our state were you
upset the Justice Kennedy a Republican
had sided with liberal members of the
court when it came to limits on abortion
rights I was personally disappointed
with that but the fact of the matter is
that Justice Kennedy has been a very
important conservative member of the
court on many very key issues Obamacare
gun rights citizens united and in many
of those instances I think he understood
that the Constitution needed to be
interpreted as it's written so he parted
company with conservatives on a few key
areas but he understands the importance
of the Constitution and the way it's
written did say in a debate that he
wanted to pick someone who eliminate roe
v wade which is why people are a little
nervous some people are a little nervous
about it well for those of us for those
servitors are happy about it yes yeah
well for those of us who've been in this
business a long time
it's not about overturning particular
cases it's really about making sure you
get the constitution right you go
wherever the words take you is there a
leading contender for you
no there's not really not no it's the
list is really good they're not in order
you're just saying no no no you can
throw a dart at that list and in my view
you'd be fine Leonard I hope you will
come back we appreciate you being here